تمثل الوثائق الاستخباراتيه المسربه وثائق
الاحاطات اليوميه لكبار القاده العسكريين
الامريكيين واللفت ان النصيب الاكبر منها
تعلق بحرب روسيا على اوكرانيا فما ابرزوا
ما تضمنته تكشف الوثائق مدى اختراق
الولايات المتحده لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ومجموعه فاجنر من خلال اعتراض نظم
الاتصالات والتنصت عليها مشيره الى تحذير
مسؤول امريكيين من تعرض جواسيس المخابرات
الامريكيه للعزله والخطر لكنها بالمقابل
ترسم صوره خاتمه بشان افق هجوم مضاد مرتقب
الربيع المقبل وتحدثت عن مكاسب محدوده
للاوكرانيين مع تحذير تقييمات الاستخبارات
الامريكيه من مسمته هنا وقصه في حشد
القوات الاوكرانيه وامدادها وفق صحيفه
واشنطن بوست ورجحت الوثيقه ان قوه
الدفاعات الروسيه وانخفاض تزويد القوات
الاوكرانيه بالذخيره قد يضاعفان الخسائر
اثناء الهجوم ويؤديان الى انهيار نظام
الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني قصه بالمقابل
اثيرت لكن هذه المره مع مصر حيث كشفت
صحيفه واشنطن بوست ان احدى الوثائق السريه
المسربه اشرت الى وجود امر من السلطات
المصريه بانتاج اربعين الف الصاروخ ليتم
شحنها سرا الى روسيا مع خطه لتزويد موسكو
بقذائف المدفعيه والبارود في المقابل نقلت
الصحيفه عن المتحدث باسم الخارجيه المصريه
قوله ان موقف مصر قائم على عدم تدخل في
الحرب في اوكرانيا بينما تحدثت واشنطن عن
عدم رصد اي مؤشرات على ان مصر تقدم اسلحه
لروسيا من جانب اخر افادت وكاله
الى وثيقه امريكيه مسربه بان الجواسيس
امريكيين التقطوا اشاره من ضباط مخابرات
روس وهم يتفاخرون باقناعهم الاماراتيين
بالعمل معهم ضد وكيلتي المخابرات
الامريكيه والبريطانيه لكن الوكاله نقلت
عن بيان خاص من الحكومه الاماراتيه رفضها
لمسمته المزاعب المتعلقه باتفاق لتعمق
التعاون بين